how many people here like that old final
fantasy style
let's get on with the gameplay
[Music]
what's going on you guys lord out here
coming at you for another lords review
today we're going to be reviewing live
alive it is kind of a 16-bit old style
type of rpg you know those games that we
used to play final fantasy
5 4 you guys get the drift uh got my
hands on this it's for the nintendo
switch you know there's a lot of things
i want to go into this i actually have a
lot of opinions on this game i know i
might upset some people it seems like
when i'm looking on twitter it's the
greatest game ever made and uh you know
i agree with some of the critiques i've
been seeing but you know first thing i
want to really talk about in this game
is the art style i actually feel like
it's unique
you know it's it's that 16-bit thing you
know a lot of people are going to
gravitate towards because the nostalgia
reasons i myself like this type but you
know i generally got into the final
fantasy brand when i was playing like
seven so it didn't really resonate
wasn't a lot of nostalgia for me but i
can't appreciate the art style that this
game has going for it's got that art
style that five to ten years from now
still gonna be relevant people are still
gonna remember that live alive or live
alive i don't know what the name is
really to be honest with you uh but i
can't really shame them too much on the
art style on this game one thing i will
say though is you know when it comes to
the performance you guys don't have the
nintendo switches
yeah i felt like this would have ran
better on a on a pc
a toaster anything else besides the
nintendo switch but i can't say that i
had like huge issues with performance
but there was stuttering every now and
then you know i had a couple crashes
there was this an incident at the end of
the game that kind of glitched on me i
don't know if it was supposed to happen
uh but it didn't happen so you know keep
that in mind there are a little bit of
performance issues now like i said it's
a 16-bit game it does run relatively
okay on the nintendo switch but i would
prefer this to be on more platforms so i
could have actually played this at a
better performance in general you know
first i want to talk about the story on
live alive
it's actually a decent story i can't
really have any kind of complaints
there's actually seven unique stories
there's a little bit more secret stuff
to offer that i won't really go too much
into because i don't want to spoil the
game for anyone um you know stories can
change depending on what you do during
the play through now it there's not a
lot of incidences this happened but
there was an incident where you know
they kind of put the highlight on a
certain character and the choices that
you make during that story of that
unique character might change the
overall aspect of how that story ends
that was interesting how that went
through not a lot of stuff that goes
into that but one thing i will say about
the story that i i want to point out to
you guys is you know as good as this
story was it did feel like square wanted
to tell seven individual stories and not
one story that combines characters you
know i kind of thought something like
octopad traveler where the characters
eventually come together now i'm not
going to say if they come together or
not you know that's kind of spoiling
territory uh but i will say is i was
expecting a more unique cohesive story
at the end that explained why you want
and care about these characters on an
individual level and i kind of felt like
it let me down a little bit on that and
i'm not going to say it was like the
most letdown thing but i do feel like
there should have been a lot more
thought process to the final chapter and
you guys know what i mean by that once
you get closer to the end of the game i
feel like there should have been a
little bit more information on that uh
but it's like i said the seven stories
individually they're okay not not all of
them are great i do feel like a couple
of them could have went missing from
this game and it wouldn't have really
messed with the overall aspect of the
story i did feel like some of the
stories was relevant to what was going
on and i enjoyed playing some of them
but some of them i'm like nah that ain't
it that could have went somewhere but it
is what it is i'm not gonna say that you
know those individuals i would say out
of the seven unique stories that i
played on here i didn't like maybe two
of them and you know it doesn't
necessarily mean that's a subjective
opinion i'm sure
40 people watching this is going to have
the same opinion me and i'm sure 150
you're gonna have a different opinion
because it seems like you guys like
disagreeing with me but you know let's
get on with the gameplay because you
guys know that's the only thing i really
care about it's turn based guys know how
final fantasy is persona you know you
got that 16-bit thing it's not really
you know gravitating in towards of uh
animations or anything like that can't
say the animations are bad i feel like
the animations are pretty good on the
game but i will say is when i play these
type of games i always feel like the
class system and the job system that
final fantasy and a lot of these other
developers have picked up on this i mean
this was made by square enix
it doesn't have really a job system in
it and look that doesn't necessarily
mean the game's bad but if you don't
have a standard job system those old
type of standard rpgs you got to do
something to make up for it and i do
feel like the lacking of customization
on top of classes that you want you know
where you can mismatch classes depending
on what your major job system is your
minor job system where that was lacking
in this game and when i mean lacking
non-existent it felt like the game play
was more pretty much like you're going
to play this game how the game wants you
to play not necessarily how you want to
play but one thing i will give props to
this game is how they did the rewards of
this for those of you that know
sometimes when you play other rpgs takes
forever unlockabilities
sometimes you can go three or four
levels of outlooking abilities
live a life is not that type of game
every level you get rewarded with a nice
new ability that you can use and i
actually had like kind of a destiny like
sensation going on where i wanted to
know what was gonna happen next what
ability i was going to unlock and there
has like a weakness system that's going
on in this game you know they'll be on
the bottom left and you know i'll try to
show it in the gameplay that's going on
will show what they're weak to and what
they're resistant for now the majority
of these characters they have unique
fashions that put them in multiple of
these categories but i didn't really
come across anyone that had all of them
so you know i do think there's a little
bit of balance going on there you know
you want to complement the team
depending on who you're fighting and you
want to kind of make sure you have at
least one in all those categories there
there'll be some bosses that don't care
about their weaknesses they'll be like
we ain't weak to nothing and you're just
gonna hit us with neutral attacks over
and over again until you eventually
succeed now i won't say that this
happens a lot for the most part the
majority of the enemies you're going to
come across they have weaknesses and i
think the game does a really good job at
like i said rewarding the player for
every level they level up there's a lot
of different aspects to stories that
goes into this i do feel like some of
the characters had really solid
abilities and some of the characters i
probably wouldn't have really chose them
you know they could have did a little
bit better with some of the abilities
maybe it's because they gave you so many
that they had a couple useless ones but
i wouldn't say if i were to put a scale
on maybe 80 20 were you know useless 20
being the useless ones another thing i
didn't really like about the game is the
lack of store innovation in the game i
really appreciate these types that you
can go to these new towns when you get
to them and you know the first place i
generally like to go is the stores they
didn't really have any to be honest with
you and maybe it's because they were
telling seven individual stories they
didn't really want to focus on
individual stores because some don't
really give you the opportunity to have
a store but what i will say is at the
end of the day i don't think that really
that's me nitpicking more than anything
they do give you plenty of access to any
type of equipment you know a lot of
random houses that goes throughout the
game will have sores and shields on the
wall so maybe it's a little bit more
realistic with how you find equipment
but i do think they should have been a
little bit more focused on you know
stores in general it would have been
nice to be able to create stuff too they
kind of had like a thing at the
beginning of one of the stories where
you can create abilities but i didn't
feel like towards later on in the end of
the game that actually was accessible it
might have been accessible towards the
last couple of chapters but i didn't
personally find it i also felt like
a certain abilities were unique to
certain characters but after you did
that story they kind of were irrelevant
at that time so it's just like look i
get it they wanted to bring more
in-depth in terms of gameplay but it's
just like you could have actually saved
a little bit of time than programming
those abilities and just had you know
good unique fighting abilities instead
of passive abilities happen outside of
battle and i'm not going to say that
they weren't cool they were entertaining
for a couple minutes but it's like i
said after
the initial chapter the ability was used
on it's like i said it didn't feel like
it was going to be relevant then going
forward so it's like if you only use it
for like maybe an hour of gameplay why
even having it at all but that's just my
opinion on the matter but overall you
know live alive yeah it's like i said
the artwork of this game is a very
unique type of artwork and i don't think
that type is going to go anywhere
anytime soon most 16 bits generally go
this direction when they make their
games and i respect it you know i feel
like we could try some new things
industry you know especially square enix
because it looks like you are making the
majority of these games you know try
something new when it comes to art style
you know performance you know square
stop selling games to the switch or
demand them to make better hardware like
i said it's not like i could tell that
the hardware was missing on here but i
know for a fact if i would have played
this on a pc or even one of the you know
current gen consoles hell i probably
would have got better performance from a
ps4 or an xbox one and that's not
nothing really knocking on the switch
like i said it's a 16-bit game i'm sure
that you know whatever you experience in
this game is going to be fine for you
for the most part the performance was
fine for me just a little bit of knacks
here and there you know the unique
stories could have been better you know
some of them could have been better some
of them were okay and some of them were
really good i really enjoyed uh you know
a lot of the aspects when it comes to
story the biggest gripe i have to say is
just like you know the last couple
chapters you know i feel like this i
think is a remake from an older title
and if they brought back identical from
those previous games into here without
changing anything shame on them uh you
know the the past couple chapters in
this game made no sense to me felt like
characters didn't understand what was
going on and you know they expected me
to understand what's going on like look
you're telling me the story not the
other way around you know scoring this
tell me the story don't make me
hypothesize what's going on i didn't
really enjoy that part of the game like
you know as far as being worth 50 i am
you know that's subjective you know if
you enjoyed those old-style 16-bit games
which i'm sure a lot of you did you know
maybe this game is worth your time and i
can't say that i didn't have fun playing
this game i did i got about i would say
25 hours it's like said the gameplay
it's kind of like that grid space
tactics game that's mixed with an rpg
it's not exactly like tactics but it is
a little bit more grid space than most
of these type of games and i would say
it is worth trying out now 50 is a
little steep if you like these type of
games you know i would say that is a
good
sensation by itself for you to go pick
it up but even if you're on the fence at
all and you know this is not going to be
one of those things where if you don't
like turn-based games this is going to
get you like in turn-based games you're
going to [ __ ] the whole time you're
playing if you don't like turn-based
games i would not recommend this game to
anyone that doesn't like turn-based
games and to be honest with you guys
even if you like turn-based games i
would probably wait for a sale for this
game maybe 20 30 bucks i feel like would
be a better price point for this it's
like i said it's not a bad game by any
means i think it was actually a pretty
decent solid game it's just as far as
the performance is up and down a little
bit on this game and so you know some
story inconsistencies in it i do feel
like there's better stuff going on you
know octopad travelers a good solid game
you can play instead there's a lot of
other games on the switch that you know
in my opinion are just better than this
game and you know like i don't want to
be one of those people that convince you
not to buy the game if you do enjoy
these type of games you will enjoy this
game i'm telling you that your money is
spent better somewhere else that's just
my personal opinion you know i didn't
pay for it so it doesn't really matter
to me but i don't think this is worth
the 50. but you know tell me what you
guys think in the comment section but
like i said you know artworks pretty
good performance is up and down you know
the story's okay i felt like it could
have been drastically better gameplay
was phenomenal love the gameplay it's
just i don't feel like the game's worth
50 but you know put in the comment
section below is this something that you
guys are interested in i know that a lot
of people are really hyping this game up
and i'm not going to really say too much
about their hype but they love this game
then i hope they love this game i'm
always down for people enjoying games
that's in this industry to me it was
overhyped and uh that's where i'm
standing with but you know that is the
review for live alive i hope you guys
enjoyed it was for the nintendo switch
developed by square enix and published
by nintendo if you guys enjoyed this
review definitely hit that like button
we always appreciate it man if you guys
enjoyed it why would you like the video
if you like podcaster you know talking
in general definitely catching into the
iron lures podcast every sunday at 1 p.m
that's not football season and at
football season 11 a.m attic shows every
wednesday at 5 p.m and you know i hope
you guys enjoyed the review and until
next review lord addict i hope you guys
have a good day